[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on va parler télé bien sûr dans un
instant réparation si la perla et les
solutions là comme je respectais
téléspectateurs qui viennent de nous
prendre tout de suite j'ai un dossier
sur serena hanouna il a à faire nous
affirme que là qu'on a coproduit avec
jean rachid un simon a fait en galère
une autoproduction en galère il n'a
jamais vu les roches il a jamais vu mais
on n'a rien vu
donc là c'est juste pour vous il y avait
tout non comme un ben ouais ça
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
on va leur sort directement dans le
temps comment commercer vanity alors
c'est parti témoin je n'essaie jamais
plus les excès mais je jouais quoi déjà
dedans je pense plus à lajunie nurullah
là bas les gens achètent des joueurs
charkaoui et sans que son père lui mais
un ultimatum et son père lui dit ben ça
suffit les conneries folle tu arrêtes de
racketter les merguez frites wright
arrête de raquette et tout le monde dans
paris il faut que tu te maries mais le
problème est il amoureux de nine ou non
le problème c'est que c'est un problème
pour lui et bien et pas pour d'autres
c'est il aime les garçons ah ouais un
problème pour son père c'est un problème
ah oui et toi toi tu es la petite déjà
rachat
[Applaudissements]
est parti 16 avant de traiter mais c'est
bon j'ai trouvé un distributeur aurait
fait que le petit ami de jean du genre à
chier j'ai jamais vu ces images
regardez là c'est un gros dossier
tu prends tes mère déclic tourner
constituent des gages
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est tout
je ne peux que sur la tête c'est toi qui
l'avait ramené ce bordel ambiant
on est passé en plateau mémoriser et
d'une base et d'une phrase qui est un
classique qui va rester dans le dans le
cinéma français grave et jean rachid et
rentrent avec le plein comme ça tu dis
regard arrêt que j'ai fait un couscous
al arabia tas d'excusés à larabia ça
n'existe pas et elle a vanté sa le coup
ce cas là il ya un deuxième extrait un
deuxième
[Applaudissements]
la bretagne où l'ailé s'il vous plaît
chaque lot d'amour celui là je
reconnaissais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le marseillais a ses raisons
et là tu vends le film bien combien
distributeurs là franchement appelé
n'ont jamais débuté sur ses rails il a
fait un contre un et c'est là on peut
s'amuser à jouer sinon je suis obligé -
cyril hanouna
oui interprétant le personnage de ninon
dans le film la dernière passe partout
jusque là vous avez mimi nous donc je
veux bien oui mais beaucoup
d'accord c'est quoi ces décès étaient
coupées ou pas parce qu'ils ont très
bien et dans la dernière scène dans la
seine qui ressemble mais qui a gagné
l'eurovision
j'avais dit parce que mes budget qu'on
produit par genre à celle d'un test sur
l'honneur en présence de passy et d'un
million de téléspectateurs que je donne
les pleins pouvoirs à stomy bugzy en dvd
et vod mais mon cassettes vhs support
présents et à venir c'est vous avez
prises par la présence et à utiliser mon
image gracieusement un bébé c'est fait
c'est fait
[Musique]
c'est vrai que celui des affaires
[Applaudissements]